alors qu'harry on se souvient qu'à la
sortie de ton d'abord autant d'albums
cultes est venu nous voir d'ailleurs or
noir
tu disais que tu allais pas faire du rap
toute ta vie on est toujours le cas ou
pas bien sûr que tu vas faire tu veux
faire autre chose complètement au tu
veux faire un autre style de musique
non je veux faire je continue mais je
pense que je vais faire autre chose
bachand retour dans la vie tu veux faire
quoi une confiserie aussi bass rec est
envie de faire du beau monde débute en
chocolat allez on apprend qu'il va
vendre des dragibus non mais qu'est ce
que tu aimes dans la vie c'est qui c'est
quoi tu as envie de faire quoi s'ils
arrêtent le rapstar est de chanter on se
mange pas du tout mais j'en fais tous un
petit duo avec moi peut-être sympa
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça me tirait mec de
l'agitateur tous les deux ont fait une
ovation ra 2 il
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais m
des morceaux bout la côte a sorti en
juillet afin d' énormes pertes ont 2 8
millions de stream en une semaine alors
que le clip fut mule 17 millions de vues
déjà tu t'attendais à un retour aussi
forme pendant mon nom technique était
content je suis content je suis content
ça fait du bien tu as travaillé comme un
fou sur la voie travail comment ouf avec
l'équipe tout fondement en interview tu
dis j'ai pas réussi à me faire aimer des
gens dès qu'il ya un projet avec moi je
me fais descendre avant même que ça
existe c'est pas vrai ça ya plein de
gens qui t'aiment voilà des gens qui
m'aiment pas trop choquer mais tu jeu ne
sortirait pas indemne
cet amour avec moi
voyez pas que je chante très bien j'ai
beaucoup d'amis je vois pas tu penses
que tu as beaucoup de lecteurs bon je
pense comme chaque artiste eu dans la
dans la rue les gens te reconnaissent
les gens comme vous dans la rue sont
contents de masse et ça va au fond d'un
petit réussite tu dis c'est que des
commentaires et des tweets c'est le prix
de la russie parce que quoi sur les
réseaux se soit tu te fais beaucoup
attaqué moi je les ai vécus comme
beaucoup d'artistes mais c'est vrai que
c'est bien vécu c'est bien bien vécu je
trouve qu'il ya trop de haine trop d'
attaques sur les réseaux
mais ça va tranquille en ce moment le
site twitter y sont cordialement
ça va tranquille alors tu collabores
avec nîmes avec la douce et twitter
tombait collabore à ginza y joue avec
gauche c'est qu'il rappeur doc est le
plus proche en ce moment c'est non non
non je suis pro je suis proche de calage
criminelle de sch d'accord projet aussi
avec madou
c'est vraiment on sait la famille mais
ça c'est les frire ou alors on leur fait
des gros bisous paul sont tous les jours
bon c'est le poteau alors étoile
montante et je suis très très fier
d'avoir posé là vu que ces derniers